hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña juan josé martínez 2 wilson
el ex periodista y antropólogo experto
en temas de pandillas hablamos de uno de
los principales investigadores y también
referentes en lo que son los estudios e
investigaciones sobre estos grupos
juanjosé muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
gracias por invitarme a santiago y
gracias por tu generosa presentación no
por favor gracias a ti una vez más como
decía sos un referente absoluto en lo
que son las investigaciones sobre las
pandillas centroamericanas tu libro ver
oír y callar de hecho es fruto de un año
de convivencia con integrantes de la
mara salvatrucha
13 en este libro podemos leer que estos
grupos integrantes de estos grupos no os
voy a citar te tuvieron que pasar muchas
cosas no para que estos jóvenes marcarán
sus cuerpos con esas famosas dos letras
no a la que estamos acostumbrados a
verlos me refiero a sus tatuajes porque
se acumularon contingencias decís en el
libro también casualidades injusticias y
desigualdades no ellos generan violencia
pero crees que de alguna manera son
también producto de otro tipo de
violencias
si mira ese libro en realidad es
producto de mi tesis de grado de una
tesis académica que elabore en la
universidad nacional del salvador
y esto pues fueron insumos en mi diario
de campo justamente en el tema de
pandillas
yo prefiero no usar las categorías de
víctima y victimario porque son el fondo
categorías morales que tratan de hablar
y bueno y malo y si bien esto tiene
sentido a nivel social y a nivel
personal a nivel académico creo que son
categorías que no nos aportan sobre todo
porque son categorías muy estáticas
utilizo unas que son un poco más
flexibles que es emisor de violencia y
receptor de violencia creo que es más
preciso a la hora de definir fenómenos
tan complejos como las pandillas
efectivamente de hecho creo que las
pandillas como bien lo decías son
producto de una serie de desigualdades y
de procesos históricos
locales algunos globales otros pero son
al final
el resultado de toda una trayectoria y
sobre todo son el producto de una
sociedad y luego de un conjunto de
sociales de sociedades que le han
apostado a la violencia como forma más
eficiente de resolver sus problemas como
bien decía bueno son producto de un
proceso no en esta línea abordar lo que
es la historia de las maras de las
pandillas implica a retroceder en el
tiempo no en la historia ir a mediados
del siglo 20 a eeuu contanos cuán donde
se podría encontrar por decirlo de
alguna manera no la semilla el germen no
de las madres de estos grupos mira las
pandillas las maras
que son pandillas de origen californiano
por al sol de hoy al menos la mara
salvatrucha es una mafia de origen
pandillero de origen californiano y
empiezan en la ciudad de los ángeles en
el sur de california con población en un
primer momento con con mexicanos como es
el caso de la pandilla varrio 18 y otra
serie de pandillas que se conocen como
pandillas sureñas
el caso de la mara salvatrucha digamos
una pandilla más de factura
centroamericana
se forma por refugiados y por migrantes
que huyeron en el último quinquenio de
los 70 y durante todos los 80 huyendo
del conflicto político militar en el
salvador y de los principios del
conflicto político militar que pulso
mucha gente del campo a la ciudad pero
también mucha gente del campo hacia
fuera del país y pues en esos años y lo
sigue siendo
california pero sobre todo el sur de
california es uno de los lugares más
económicamente más activos en más
crecimiento más ricos y era donde había
más trabajo y donde habían algunas redes
de migración y pues los salvadoreños
ante la adversidad migran a los ángeles
en donde generan esta etapa andía
originalmente muy pequeña que ahora se
ha extendido pues por casi todos los
estados de los eeuu y que ha
evolucionado de una manera muy difícil
de prever en centroamérica
juan en ver oír y callar conta que las
pandillas doblegaron o de cierta manera
al gobierno del salvador por ejemplo con
negociaciones con penas más bajas con
traslados a prisiones que tienen quizás
regímenes menos rigurosos no se puede
gobernar en el salvador o en otros
países de centroamérica sin alcanzar
algunos acuerdos con las maras
mirar lo que sucede en centroamérica
pero sobre todo en el salvador que
sucede con esa tregua de la que yo me
refiero ese libro cierro el libro con la
tregua la tregua las negociaciones del
gobierno de mauricio funes con los
líderes de las pandillas se dan entre
finales del 11 y principios del 12 que
es justo cuando publicó el libro
justamente por eso cierro el libro con
con el inicio de esas negociaciones es
un atajo es un atajo que decidieron
tomar algunos gobernantes el primero fue
mauricio funes es un atajo que
teóricamente no es
incorrecto es decir sumar a las
estructuras a la solución del problema
teóricamente pues no sería tan
desatinado probablemente tenga que ver
la nada con la grave consecuencia que
hemos visto tenga que ver con cómo lo
han hecho no en vez de a solucionar las
causas profundas que generan pandillas
en vez de atajar y meterte de lleno a
las raíces que hacen que muchos jóvenes
vean como opción la pandilla pues
decidieron hacer un acuerdo con la
pandilla no para y desarticularlas sino
para bajar uno de los de las actividades
de las pandillas que más obstaculizaban
la gobernabilidad que eran los
asesinatos no entonces no le apostaron a
que disminuyeran los asesinatos
productos que disminuían las causas
sociales que generan la pandilla no sino
que hicieron un acuerdo con las
pandillas para que dejaran de matar al
menos por un tiempo y esto tiene como
consecuencia
que las pandillas entran al campo
político del salvador
y entran en contacto y se vuelven
interesantes y se vuelven jugosas para
todas las fuerzas políticas salvadoreñas
en tanto que se dan cuenta de algo que
antes no sabían las maras están rodeadas
de toda una carne social de todo un
tejido social de toda una montaña social
que se puede traducir en votos
y desde ese momento todas las fuerzas
políticas incluyendo el gobierno de
nuevas ideas del presidente nadie bukele
incluyéndolo todas las fuerzas políticas
han coincidido en algo hay que buscar a
los líderes pandilleros hay que buscar a
las pandillas para hacer campaña
política para que aquello se traduzca en
votos y luego en gobernabilidad
juan hablaba recién del gobierno de
nadie bukele y el salvador decretó el
estado de excepción no para controlar la
violencia en este contexto que está
describiendo hoy hay una arremetida
contra los comunicadores contra
periodistas investigadores y te tocó a
buzz muy en particular bueno pongámosle
un poco de contexto no juan porque el
congreso de el salvador recordemos
aprobó una reforma al código penal se
establecieron sanciones no contra los
comunicadores que reproduzcan o que
transmitan mensajes sobre las pandillas
se presienten al hip hop que le tuiteó
un vídeo dirigido a vos no un extracto
de una entrevista que te habían
realizado te insultó te trató de basura
cómo recibiste esas declaraciones y cómo
evaluar la política de bucles en sí
misma y también en comparación con las
de otros mandatarios
son varias preguntas en una vamos a
responder las en orden lo primero si hay
que poner el contexto estoy de acuerdo
el contexto es el gobierno de ney book
que le tiene más o menos dos años yo no
sé si le llamaría negociando porque ha
sido un gobierno muy hermético pero ha
tenido dos años al menos al menos
comprobados en donde ha tenido diálogos
constantes con las élites de las
pandillas con la mara salvatrucha y las
dos facciones de la pandilla varrio 18
al interior de los centros
penitenciarios donde ellos se encuentran
incluso facilitando a través del
gobierno facilitando encuentros de
pandilleros en el penal compañeros en la
cárcel que esto con el objetivo de bajar
los homicidios
y con el objetivo de apoyo electoral así
lo consigna la investigación de la
fiscalía nacional de la república la
fiscalía anterior que fue destituida por
bucle por cierto y puso a un fiscal
nuevo justamente para que no salieran a
la luz a estas investigaciones
es solo que consignaban y luego lo
amplían investigan investigaciones
periodísticas del periódico 'el faro' y
que son unos colegas muy queridos
resulta que esta negociación esta línea
de comunicación se ha roto al menos
sabemos en tres ocasiones una es
durante el 2020 durante la lo más fuerte
de la pandemia donde el estado tenía
tomadas las calles algo salió mal en la
cadena de comunicación entre el gobierno
y las pandillas y las pandillas
pusieron a aproximadamente 90 muertos en
un fin de semana luego será otro quiebre
de esta línea de comunicación entre el
gobierno de buques y las pandillas en el
en noviembre del 2021
donde nuevamente en un fin de semana en
pocos días ponen una gran cantidad de
muertos orbitando los 90 y los 90
asesinatos y la última será en 26 de
marzo alrededor del 26 de marzo de este
año donde pues es lo mismo no ponen
aproximadamente 90 muertos en muy pocos
días en cada una de estas y el gobierno
ha tratado de responder con mucha fuerza
en esta ocasión ha respondido con con
muchísima fuerza también tratando de
capturar a todo aquello que de alguna
manera abuela a pandillas hoy por hoy
hay al menos 20.000 capturados o es lo
que dice el gobierno yo pondría
cualquier cifra del gobierno de buque l
la pusiera en salmuera pero pero 20 mil
es lo que se dice es probable que los
haya lo que es improbable que sean 20
mil pandillas claro que es muy difícil
hablar de cifras y de porcentajes sería
un poco irresponsable pero yo me
atrevería a decir que menos de la mitad
son realmente pandilleros o pertenecen
al tejido social de la pandilla y esto
pues es si lo ven desde un punto de
vista social y de drama humano es muy
[__]
las negociaciones
murieron asesinaron a personas civiles
que no tenían absolutamente nada que ver
con pandillas las pandillas los matarlo
y cuando el gobierno responde responde
justamente
aterrorizando capturando y torturando a
esta misma población que no estuvieron
involucrados en la tregua y esto es un
drama humano muy profundo no lo hagas
pero nos queda poco tiempo pero no
quiero dejar de hacerte la siguiente
pregunta porque en alguna oportunidad
dijiste algo muy interesante llamativo
que la violencia no termina con acuerdos
de paz sino que se transforma podría
desarrollar por favor esta idea
si mira lo que hemos visto con las
pandillas es que tienen una capacidad de
mutación muy muy afinada no los acuerdos
la violencia que es algo profundo en el
salvador que son que tiene que ver con
valores y normas y concepciones y
sentido del mundo muy profundos no se
van a resolver firmando papeles o
haciendo arreglos o haciendo treguas no
tiene que ver con atajar las causas que
nos vuelven una sociedad violenta tiene
que ver y esa es una apuesta importante
y difícil y cara transformar aquellos
valores que nos vuelven una sociedad
violenta la violencia no sólo se expresa
en asesinatos sino en una serie de
actitudes sociales muy amplia y no se
van a acabar así como no se acabó la
violencia la historia lo ha confirmado
no se terminó la violencia con los
acuerdos de paz de 1992 entre la
guerrilla y los gobiernos de derecha
tampoco se ha terminado ni se va a
terminar la violencia con los acuerdos
de diferentes gobernantes incluyendo a
la ibu que le y los altos mandos de las
pandillas
y formar así como se transformó la
violencia de los 80 se están formando
otra cosa pues ésta tiene potencial es
de transformarse siempre y cuando no
tenemos las cosas vea se nos acabó el
tiempo seguiría estando contigo
muchísimo más te agradezco muchísimo su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
gracias a ustedes por invitarme gracias
a ti a nuestra audiencia sigan en
france24 y también en france mit y
cuatro.com
[Música]